[Music]
tom cruise is back in top gun maverick
but don't forget about his wingman why
are some fans upset about val kilmer's
role in the long-awaited sequel keep
watching to find out warning spoilers
ahead for top gun maverick if you were
expecting top gun maverick to indulge in
these same iconic moments from the 1986
films by way of dogfights and volleyball
games you'd be wrong the super sonic
2022 sequel breaks the mold by giving us
dog fights and beach football this time
around jokes aside maverick does an
excellent job honoring the legendary
staple of 80 cinema that came before it
besides the incredible aerial spectacles
and tom cruise's diamond cut grin being
on constant display due to all the fun
that he's having maverick spends time
reuniting two icons in what might be the
most heartwarming scene of the entire
movie you were here at the request of
admiral kazansky aka iceman the
on-screen pairing in question comes with
pete maverick mitchell paying a visit to
his rival-turned-friend tom iceman
kazansky seeing val kilmer as one of the
few original cast members reprising his
role it's an appearance that cruz
himself pushed to include as being
integral to the new top gun chapter
after being diagnosed with throat cancer
in 2015 and going through both
chemotherapy and two tracheostomies
kilmer recently announced that he was
cancer-free but lost his voice as a
result nevertheless kilmer's appearance
as iceman is just as impactful with the
former foes having a heartfelt down and
leading to what is easily one of the
most memorable scenes in the film you
can be my wingman anytime ultimately
though this heart to heart talk leads to
what could be one of the poorest plot
decisions in top gun maverick teased as
soon as our hero returns to base in the
new sequel the former top of the class
candidate is informed that iceman
suggested maverick train the new
recruits and see if they've got the
right stuff to those who haven't gone
over the cast list with a fine-tooth
comb following the film's announcement
it'd be fair to assume that the
appearance of kilmer's gum chewing alter
ego goes as far as a framed photo at the
academy and not much else instead the
film takes an emotional and impactful
step by having maverick's former wingman
sitting down in an office and telling
the seasoned hotshot what's what it's a
perfectly executed moment that could
induce a minor tearing up and deservedly
so given the history between maverick
and iceman from the original top gun as
well as kilmer's well-documented health
issues iceman talking through messages
on a computer makes for an effective
sequence thanks to kilmer who manages to
steal the scene with a glance or smile
that fits perfectly it's also fitting
that iceman is the only one to make
cruz's legendary hero face as demons
however that all gets undercut thanks to
a creative choice that feels totally out
of place while it's an understandable
choice to include kilmer's real-life
condition in top gun maverick the most
questionable decision is having iceman
finally succumb to them for a moment
that doesn't feel earned or necessary
when mav turns up at the iceman
household he's told by the now admiral's
wife that his cancer has returned and
that they've not told anybody as he
doesn't have much longer shortly after
and following tensions already rising
back on the base maverick has told the
news that his friend has sadly passed
away it's an event that sends mixed
messages which never quite land for
maverick's character arc is his former
comrade's passing supposed to finally
alert him to the fact he's the last of a
dying breed or perhaps signal that he
should slow down and consider a future
that he's flown right by for the past
few years either way it's a poorly
executed tug at the heartstrings that
doesn't feel warranted additionally this
makes the possibility of seeing kilmer
standing amongst the other higher-ups
following the completed mission a far
more effective choice and more enjoyable
to see even if iceman would have died
off screen it would have been nice to
see him live long enough to celebrate
his friend's success as far as faults go
in this near perfectly designed
blockbuster this is where the movie
takes the biggest hit but one that
thankfully doesn't diminish one of the
most unexpected and effective moments
two old war heroes talking like old
friends
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]